oh yeah going for some pawns  and everything is pointing towards e3  porn it falls off the board okay still a  lot of danger for the black king looking  very good now for liam lido he has won a  pawn his piece is very nicely  centralized the only slight danger is  the black king if white can somehow get  the other rook around to attack that  king but it seems very safe the black  king at the moment okay here comes the  rook but where's it going uh liam lee  looking big favorite at the moment  what's happening with the  uh doodle's clock okay it looks like he  had a couple of seconds left with just a  small delay there but  uh oh dude in big trouble about to get  checkmated izzy and now there's going to  be a four ah that's the end i think over  four duda  he loses the match to liam in blitz tie  breaks a handshake of course between  these two what a win for liam in those  blitz tiebreaks winning both of the  games heartbreak for duda on his  birthday